she used to tell me about going to the
rugby club as well soon she shot my
rugby clonality she never mentioned
depression or lady at Table think she's
very bubbly
[Music]
this is part six of what happened to
Annie the last episode in our latest
story cast series from Sky News
I'm Runa do go previously in part five
we learned of claims Annie had been
depressed and this led to her dying by
suicide
I knew placidly she told me that she'd
cut it off or her here had been cut off
for some way of relieving stress I don't
know
but we're now back in Sweden for part
six in a nice story the search for
answers however as we set off on our
final journey with ghoulia and Maria to
visit Annie's grave troubling questions
remain while we're driving
let's mull over these questions
questions that at one point brought the
police investigation all the way from
Scotland to New Zealand you will
remember in part for a neat old best
friend Maria she met a retired rugby
player in Edinburgh SMUD night club
the man had apparently played for
Scotland and maybe this wasn't the first
time that he he used his his appearance
to charm women initially they got known
first time it was a drink and Andy told
me that it was a newly open bottle of
champagne but ultimately Annie was left
feeling threatened by the man who she
would later learn was not a rugby player
he said he was the look he gave Annie I
think personally but this person knew
that an e-code could reveal some really
something but to be sure police tracked
on the actual rugby player in New
Zealand and he would prove he wasn't in
Scotland at the time of Annie's death
but if there was a man who had indeed
been using this rugby players name the
police have never been able to find him
no one has tried to find this imposter
and and I have the feeling that this
person knew the rugby world very well
we ourselves have found nothing to add
to the sinister image of this so-called
impostor our focus has remained on the
most striking image in this case that of
a young Swedish girl lying dead on a
beach in Ayrshire and a mother's
desperate search for answers reporters
TV teams everybody they want to I want
to solve the case I don't know why they
think they would to me it would be
enough actually if they just point to
the problems that are in the
investigation from the first day we met
Annie's mother gu you we've tried to
shine light on these problems and in
particular preswick Beach the source of
so many unanswered questions questions
the crown office has chosen not to fully
engage with in the form of a fatal
accident inquiry or inquest refer to in
Scotland as an FA I had an FAI been
conducted way back when would I even be
having this conversation with you now
what I would say pathologist dr. Stewart
Hamilton the benefit of an inquest is
that it it will air a lot of things it
will get a lot of stuff onto the record
in a formal way you know you have people
under oath giving evidence and sometimes
it does simply end the speculation
remember speculation over Annie's death
started within hours of her passing
before she'd even been given an autopsy
her family were told it was suicide this
led to suggestions there had been a rush
to judgment and questions about what
measures the police took during the
recovery of Annie's body
in a statement sent to Sky News on
December the 15th 2019 detective
Superintendent Paul Livingston from the
specialist crime division in police
Scotland said Annie's death was fully
investigated at the time and has also
been subject to review however if this
was a thorough review she did not have
included an interview with the second
witness from the beach and responding to
how the crime scene was handled
detective Superintendent Livingston said
with any investigation where the death
has occurred outdoors or where the full
circumstances are as yet unknown the
scene would be treated as a potential
crime scene allowing for all crime scene
protocols to be put in place in order to
obtain the maximum evidence available
but according to the original autopsy
report it would appear that a provision
to gather the maximum evidence had not
been made pathologist dr. Hamilton if we
are talking about a body that is being
forensic ly recovered it would be
typical to bag the head the hands and
the feet and to put the body into a body
bag with a sealed tag so you have
continuity of evidence we he seemed to
have a bit of a halfway house here
whereby the hands are bagged but the
other procedures that would be taken
with a forensic recovery haven't been
undertaken
to understand just what's required at a
crime scene we asked a retired detective
Chief Superintendent with the
Metropolitan Police the bodies washed up
on the side that is a crime scene the
body is your crime scene and that's what
you have to preserve to make sure you've
got all the evidence because you never
can go back sue Hill built her
reputation on painstaking research and
has a wealth of experience when it comes
to dealing with questionable deaths you
can't make assumptions assume nothing
believe no one check everything and the
Devils in the detail you keep an open
mind and make sure you do everything to
the nth degree dot the i's and cross the
t's the Scottish authorities say they
discovered no proof of murder but
considering the deceased was a foreign
national and English was not the first
language of the family was there not a
greater onus on the police to prove on a
suicide and for the Swedish authorities
to demand more after the death of one of
its citizens in unusual circumstances
overseas what can you do
what will that country do for you what
we Sweden do it for you and it was a
Swedish citizen do you feel that
downplay the Swedish authorities yes of
course yeah by all parties yeah of
course
I don't trust them no coach
[Music]
so what can we see for sure well to
autopsy reports concluded Annie drowned
and to Undertaker's were left disturbed
by unrecorded markings on Annie's body
the suggestion that bruising was caused
by rough objects in the sea after death
has proven to be impossible some of
Annie's hair had indeed been cuts how
much and by whom we don't know but it's
worth mentioning that Annie's mother
ghoulia says bunches totaling nearly two
foot were missing Andrew the witness
from the beach never specifically
identified Annie on the shore and the
police never interviewed the second
witness Doug the saltwater
argaï test proved inconclusive so to the
test to find a match for the DNA sample
on Ali's hands in terms of Annie's
behavior she had been acting strangely
in the weeks before she died there is no
evidence linking Annie's death with the
CIA the family have asked that we stress
this feeling it might overshadow Annie's
case to suitably qualified pathologists
carried out Annie's autopsy in Scotland
the other thing which is very thorough
and very positive there is a description
confirming that there's no trauma that
might be related to sexual activity so
obviously these pathologists are
thinking carefully they're not just
saying body from water must be a
drowning whatever and the second autopsy
in Sweden found no evidence Annie had
been using medication or drugs there was
a small amount of alcohol in her system
but it demonstrated only moderate use
possibly from the night before
medication screening negative in muscle
tissue amphetamine negative in muscle
tissue
MDMA MDA MDE a negative in muscle tissue
morphine and codeine negative in muscle
tissue what we can't see for certain is
that decomposition is the reason for the
Bruce Lake markings on Annie's head that
the tide washed Annie along with her
jacket and bag to the high point she was
found on the beach and the reason the
CCTV images never matched up is because
the cameras were set two different times
according to one security insider yet
there are also things we may never know
Annie was wearing a second green colored
jacket the day she was last seen on CCTV
it's never been found
police also failed to find her Filofax a
potential treasure trove of personal
thoughts and contacts but if Annie left
a suicide note here would she not have
made sure to leave the Filofax where
someone would find it and why after
traveling for more than two and a half
hours did Annie spend just over four
minutes in the airport and then leave
then there's the fact her visit to the
carpark
took place out of sight of CCTV and why
would choose a foam box at nights in
winter to call home instead of the phone
at Lenten Court at the same time we have
been forced to consider Annie's
emotional well-being her family says she
had no history of mental health issues
but did she leave the airport in
desperation because she was unable to
withdraw the money to get home this
despite being an advanced month's rent
and the recovery of a 300 pound cheque
from her apartment we must also accept
that Annie was dealing with something we
anti-family know nothing about
I think what that really throws at us is
probably the heart of this story
pathologist dr. Hamilton an
oceanographer will do excellent work
about what the sea does the pathologists
do that work about what the sea does to
you they will do the work about the
drowning but the one element that we
can't get into is that element of human
behavior and decision-making you can
have broad ideas of what people will do
but this is potentially about or really
it's about what was in Annie's head at
that moment and potentially what is in
another person's head at that moment and
those are the things that are the most
difficult to drill down into we
originally came to this story through
the lens of Kenneth Roy's Scottish
review articles because he passed away
in 2018 we never got the chance to catch
up with Kenneth but we have found
ourselves pulled back and forth between
the extreme positions in this story at
certain times we felt sure Annie was
murdered at the times we've not been so
sure lately we felt suicide the most
likely explanation but while the
likelihood of suicide remains the way
the case has been handled nothing can be
ruled out her father asked where she was
found one pointed in one direction and
the other police pointed in the other
direction
so how do we get to a point of closure
the family say give them their public
heating in the form of a fatal accident
inquiry release the post-mortem
photographs to determine whether the
bruise like markings identified by the
two Undertaker's were present on Annie's
body when she was recovered or are the
indeed decomposition carry out the salt
water test on Annie's lung sample and
offer up a detailed photographic account
of how Annie's body was recovered this
is what they've been wanting for 14
years
and the reason they keep asking is
because they've never been given
satisfactory answers political activist
Tom Minogue well I think it's left a
stain on Scotland's character or justice
on the reputation for justice and I
think it's got this unusual factor that
happened to a foreign national who had
adopted Scotland who loved Scotland and
I don't think we'd be asking for too
much for it to be reopened again and
properly resourced inquiry taken on
board all the things that have happened
and taken on board most of all the the
the concerns of the mother appearance so
I don't think that would be asking for
too much
your other children yeah how have they
been impacted or affected by well maybe
her her brother was the closest he was
the oldest and he always felt
responsible for her and she was very
lively you know outgoing so it's been
very hard on him
the girls the other two girls they were
a lot more outgoing crying screaming
cursing whatever and my husband had two
strokes after this he aged ten years in
six months you really could see it on
him it took him so so so hard he doesn't
speak very much English so it felt
natural that have ordered impossible it
felt natural that I would be the one to
to make all the contacts and to go there
and then Maria started helping me so we
made a team then and I wanted to keep my
other child children out of this because
I wanted them to go on with their lives
and not get stuck in this for a long
time it's not late in the afternoon of
June the 26th 2019 so this is a church
that's very beautifully placed we arrive
at the graveyard where Ali is buried by
an old stone church on a hill
coincidentally it's the anniversary of
Ana's boreal we enter the church through
an iron gate do you believe in something
yes yes I do
I sometimes feel that she has been
trying to protect us the longer gravel
path one Greve stands out from all the
rest there it is
hello Annie not only because it's
decorated with portrait photographs in
the winter I have a picture from
Scotland where she is wearing a Scottish
cap but because it's marked with a
wooden cross we still have this wooden
cross you know everybody has these
stones and I will not put a stone before
the killer is caught I want the truth
out the reality for you is that after
this episode finishes you'll move on to
your next series and your own life but
when all the theories are stripped away
you have a family left in Sweden who can
never move on until they get their
answers because I can't lay her to rest
until I know and then there will be a
Stoke when I know who did it
when did she die I'm waiting for that
and my husband feels the same this is so
important to us I cannot put her to rest
until I know that's the way it is
they are not alone there have been other
notable cases of unexplained deaths in
Scotland cases where the crown office
decided against granting a fatal
accident inquiry and families were left
searching in the dark for answers for
Annie Boris ins family the trauma of
that decision not to grant an FEI has
shaped the last fourteen years of their
life today they are left with their
memories and sometimes now when the hear
Annie's music they see her on stage
living life to the fool
[Music]
and at other times they can't escape the
image of her body on the beach in
Scotland
[Music]
any family who loses someone in
circumstances no one can explain will
absolutely focus an old that doesn't add
up because there are so many problems
with this case to do otherwise would be
to consider the unimaginable but on
December the 16th 2019 a line of
communication opened with the Swedish
ministry for Foreign Affairs when they
responded to our request to see all
correspondence made with the Scottish
government regarding Annie's death they
are currently engaging with us on the
matter in the meantime we are left to
wonder whether a headstone will ever be
erected on Annie's grave or if Annie's
family can ever get to a point of
acceptance in terms of what they might
find out can any family of an
unexplained death one last time if you
the listener have heard anything in this
series that makes you believe you have
information that can help then please
contact us story cast at Sky dot uk' or
your nearest police station what
happened to Annie was written recorded
and produced by Robert Mohan
editing by Dave Terris studio support
radio fourth production support Chris
Scott digital Tommy curse on social
media we are using the hashtag what
happened to Annie solely cos will return
in 2020
I'm Runa Dougal thank you for listening